look at the latest numbers here in  nevada today the state reported more  than 1400 new cases  and 23 deaths both of those are well  above recent averages  our state's test positivity rate now  sits at 20 percent  we have some changes to let you know  about at kova test sites around the  valley  starting next monday texas station will  operate three days a week  and testing will be limited to 600  people that is on a first come first  served basis  also next monday unlv and cashman center  will start asking for  insurance information your provider will  be billed  to start reimbursement but you still  will not have to pay anything out of  pocket again this all starts next  monday we have information for you about  those test sites and more  on eightnewsnow.com